Well,
I called this series to psychological significance of the biblical stories for a
reason,
you know,
and the reason was that I'm partially qualified to talk about such things when I
step outside of that.
Okay.
Then I'm not where I should be.
I don't think that,
see,
I don't think that this is,
I'm not going to get this right.
I can't get the words exactly right.
This isn't about what I believe personally.
It's partly because I don't know what I believe.
I don't know what I believe the world's a very strange place.
I've had some very strange experiences in it.
I don't think it's helpful for me to to step outside my my jurisdiction and
speculate.
Precisely.
The easiest thing would be to say,
I think I said,
but I had to say today I don't think that we know what the upper limits of human
possibility are.
Yeah.
I don't know what that means.
Metaphysically.
What I do understand from the gospels is that even the accounts of Christ's
resurrection are complex and difficult to understand.
I think from reading you in large part that you can make a very strong case for
the symbolic meaning of the death and resurrection.
I think it does stand for the capacity of the human logos to die and resurrect
continually as it strives upward.
I'm not willing to say that that's all it means because I don't know what
everything means and I don't know about the fundamental metaphysics of being
like I do believe that it's accurate to construe being as a battleground between
good and evil.
I believe that.
I believe that is the most accurate way of representing being.
It's not that most accurate way of representing the objective world.
That's not the same thing.
Being is that set of experiences which we inhabit and that's only partly
objective and it's not obviously reduceable to the material.
Not In any straight forward way because we don't understand the material
substrate of being at all.
You know it's,
it's,
and when we do attempt to understand it,
say at the quantum level,
we run into mysteries that that baffle the most,
the most intelligent of us and aware.
So I'm going to have to leave the question hanging,
but partly because,
partly because I don't know what I think,
okay,
there has to be aligned between what I believe in,
what,
what I can communicate.
You don't,
what do you believe is beyond your capacity to articulate if you the most,
if the deepest levels of belief,
and I can only share with you what I have actually come understand and there's
things that I don't understand and that's definitely one of them.
I don't know how to draw a line between the symbolic significance of the
biblical events,
say the symbolic in psychological significance of the biblical events and a
metaphysics that's underneath them.
And I think you'll see the same thing in young because when you own rights,
technically,
informally,
he never talks about God.
He always talks about the image of God,
which is not the same thing.
The image of God would be your subjective experience of God.
It says nothing about the objective reality of God because your subjective
experience can't say much about objective reality,
but even in young you get this mix.
You know,
sometimes it's psychological,
but then he,
he makes a metaphysical move.
And I think that reflected also his,
the limits of his knowledge because you don't have profound revelatory
experiences if it was a very strange person,
you know?
And I,
I think
so.
I think what's best for me is to stay on the ground that I'm competent on and to
say what I can say about the psychology and to reach beyond that briefly when
it's necessary.
But other than that,
to leave it the hell alone till I understand that better.
Assuming that I ever do.